sí buenas noches juan pues se respira un
ambiente de culto de recuerdo de respeto
en homenaje a esas casi 3000 personas
que fallecieron en los atentados pero
terroristas pero también hay un ambiente
un tanto agrio por esa salida caótica de
afganistán que ha vuelto a despertar
fantasmas del pasado ha vuelto a sembrar
el miedo en algunos estadounidenses
cuando se acerca una fecha tan
importante y significativa como esta
mañana aquí donde nos encontramos
nosotros ahora mismo en la 'zona cero'
ya están preparando todo para esos actos
de conmemoración que arrancarán mañana a
las ocho y media de la mañana contando
con la asistencia como decías del
presidente joe biden y de la
vicepresidenta kamala harris se
guardarán seis momentos de silencio que
coincidirán exactamente con el momento
en el que los dos aviones se estrellan
contra las torres gemelas la torre norte
y la torre sur otros dos minutos justo
en el momento exacto en el que esas
torres gemelas se desploman y otros dos
minutos coincidirán con los ataques en
washington y en pensilvania durante todo
este tiempo los familiares de las
víctimas estarán leyendo en voz alta los
nombres de las personas que fallecieron
aquel y ya por la noche volveremos a ver
un año más esos enormes cañones haces de
luz apuntando al cielo simbolizando esas
torres gemelas caídas va a ser un
aniversario cargado de simbolismo por
ser el vigésimo pero como decía también
con este sentimiento agrio después de la
salida de las tropas de afganistán del
antes de la de este aniversario la
presencia del presidente en el punto
cero era muy controvertida porque las
familias pedían de antemano que se
desclasificarán los expedientes del 11
de septiembre él ya dio instrucciones en
ese sentido eso ha conseguido cambiar
algo en el sentido de las familias
si los familiares han agradecido este
gesto de joe biden pero advierten que
van a estar muy atentos de que realmente
cumpla sus promesas recordemos que esta
revisión de la investigación que llevó
al cabo a cabo el fbi debería hacerse
pública en un plazo de seis meses por el
fiscal general y durante ese tiempo han
dicho los familiares estarán muy
pendientes porque no quieren que esto
quede tan en tan solo una promesa así
que mañana aceptarán que venga aquí pero
con esa advertencia de que estarán muy
pendientes